I want to do something different for our
third show we're going to get away from
atheism and religion today believe it or
not and we're going to focus on another
passion of mine politics real quick
though I should thank all of you that
listened to last week's direct message
and actually took it into action you
guys are calling out the [ __ ]
artists on every social media platform
like I've never seen before as I said
last week when you guys are engaged we
can focus on other things and not just
have the same conversation over and over
I've really only been intimately
involved in this conversation for a
couple weeks fighting the lies is not
only exhausting but it has also affected
a couple of my friendships I really do
think that part of the plan by these
people is to tire out the good guys into
giving up your part in this debate is
beyond crucial but enough of that let's
talk politics I was at the GOP debate at
the Reagan Library last week I've never
been to one of these things before and I
really had no idea what to expect behind
the scenes we had a booth in the spin
room right alongside CNN MSNBC and Fox
News the fact they call it the spin room
really tells you all you need to know
about this thing this is where campaign
people and candidates go to spin their
message I went to the truth room next
door but nobody was there
weird huh we were able to snag
surrogates from pretty much every
candidate except for Carly Fiorina and
Donald Trump because neither of them
sent any reps to the floor I even got to
ask John Kasich a question about gay
marriage and Scott Walker a question
about money in politics come to think of
it maybe that's what caused him to drop
out of the race earlier this week
what I realized by being on the inside
of all this is that there are some
unspoken rules to how the game is played
I talked to Mike Huckabee's campaign
manager about gay marriage and she
basically just danced around it had I
pushed her to the breaking point I
probably would have never gotten access
to her again and then word would have
traveled fast that I'm someone that they
shouldn't talk to so with that in mind I
tried my best to navigate all the
interviews with some basic questions and
then some deeper probing I asked pretty
much everyone about campaign finance and
I really pushed on social issues it was
a big learning experience and we'll
figure out how to engage with the
candidates and the representatives in an
even more incisive way beyond the spin
and the sound bites hopefully as the
show gets bigger we'll get to more of
the debates candidates will eventually
realize that I'm going to be tough but
honest whether we agree or not we're
plotting out our plan to go to the first
democratic debate
October right now so stay tuned for that
so for today's show we're going to jump
back into the political waters I've got
two comics I like and respect Jimmy Dore
and Felicia Michaels I agree with them
on some issues and I disagree with them
on some others what I know more than
anything else though is that comedians
have a way of holding themselves to a
high standard of truth sure will get
things wrong but the good ones have a
fearless desire to say controversial
things and let the chips fall where they
may
as Billy Wilder said if you're going to
tell people the truth be funny or they
will kill you I guess you could say the
comedians are guardians of peace and
justice in the galaxy just like the Jedi
well except comedians usually smoke a
lot more weed all right so I am with two
of my favorite political comics felicia
michaels and jimmy dore most of you guys
probably recognize them from our old
show but they are new to the all-new
rubin report what do you think of this
this these digs come on it's you have a
great apartment pretty pretty sweet
jimmy we have a jib there is a camera
flying around you love the jib I do love
the jib you want you want told me the
comedy is 90% jib 90% jib and 10%
eyebrow-raising ah all right well then
we're in good shape so what I wanted to
start we're gonna do all oh that's good
so we're gonna do all politics all right
Kirk I brought you guys on for politics
I know you guys love politics so
unfortunately we have to start with
Donald Trump I hate that we have to
start this way but I feel that we do
because this is the thing that has just
consumed everything so I guess I'll just
open it sort of evenly what what do you
make of this Trump madness you know the
thing that irritates me most about
Donald Trump is how all my liberal
friends are freaking out you know I mean
they're oh he's gonna get his hands on
the button nose all that kind of
rhetoric is would you nut up the only
way he's going to get his hands on the
button is if that's what his wife calls
his penis yeah
it's just so crazy so you don't think
he's gonna become the president
you have no fears that this actually
could be legit well I I think anything
is possible I hope he doesn't become
president and I mean it's scary the
people that are attracted to him that
scares me you know that he gives a voice
to that that's frightening yeah so we'll
get to those people in a second because
I do
talk about them but the do you think
this thing is real I've been saying for
months I think he's going to do three
debates and we've already done two but I
think he's going to get to three he's
still going to be peeking in the in the
rankings and then he's going to say I
moved the dial I'm out and then he's
going to be the attack dog for whoever
the nominee is that that's my basic
prediction you know I do you think this
is real I well I say what you want about
Donald Trump he does make the racism run
on time what I do actually enjoy listen
to Donald Trump's piece is because every
once in a while you know I'm in the mood
to watch a Hitler documentary but I want
to hear it delivered by Gary Busey so
that's why I'm really he's part Hitler
part Gary Busey that kind of that kind
of work um Donald Trump I predicted he
would go away he doesn't really want to
be President he doesn't want Iran to do
anything he doesn't want to have to read
up on anything he doesn't want to have
to learn anything he doesn't want to
have to but so is that is that the
craziest part of this cuz did you see
about a week ago he was on this radio
show yeah he was reviewing it and he
asked him the difference between Hamas
and Hezbollah anyone that knows anything
about world politics anything you don't
know a lot to know that these are very
different groups one is in Gaza one is
in Lebanon and Syria and he made it
sound like it was a gotcha question what
is that the genius of him that every he
turns everything into AI you see what
the media's you ought to be is that the
real genius if that's not the genius
thing of Donald Trump would tell you the
genius here's the thing I would think
the average American doesn't know the
difference between those two factions
and it's complicated and everything is
intertwined it's not a gotcha question
anyone who's running for office should
know those answers yeah and the fact
that he can just keep going at it and
going at it and not taking any
responsibility for what he doesn't know
that's frightening you know and that
people don't call him out more right so
all right so let's talk about the people
that you mentioned these people that are
digging this because I know you you rant
and rave about politics all the time
you hate the system right I I hate the
system and what I think people are
attracted to is that he's calling the
system out on their [ __ ] so should
we at least grant him that much that he
has you know when he in the first debate
when he said well I donated money to
Hillary so she showed up to
I my wedding like should we should give
him a little credit on that kind of
thing right yes he gets a little a
little credit on that but you said what
the genius of Donald Trump is is that
the genius is that he knows it appeal to
people who are not geniuses
right right so that's he's not appealing
to smart people just like ben Carson
right so ben Carson also but I respect
Ben Carson more than I do Donald Trump
and I don't respect ben Carson at all
right well there you go
so Trump sea- Kitteridge yes so I mean
so what he's doing is he's gaining more
support Ben Carson are ironically with
racists but not gaining support with
other neurosurgeons isn't that
interesting yes what right well first of
just ben Carson real quick I mean can a
neurosurgeon not believe in evolution
don't wouldn't that be a warrant to take
your license away the stuff that he says
he said a couple of weeks ago that the
number one killer of African Americans
are abortions and one of the when he
said that I literally was like our cops
giving abortions so crazy so insane so
what do we do with this whole group I
just said in the intro to this thing
that I went to the GOP debate I talked
to a couple of these guys I think Kasich
is sort of a decent guy I think Marco
Rubio is at least in the right line of
work even if I disagree with him on a
lot of stuff but what do you think about
Trump's place in this it seems to me
they all seem like children that can't
get there the attention of their dad you
know he seems to be dad that's getting
all the attention and the kids can't
well you know you go back to his
supporters and you Donald Trump's I mean
there for instance women are is like
when he he said Carly fiorina's face you
can't have that face and then his poll
numbers went up with women who hate
themselves
yeah so that's really what's and so and
a lot of people won't say that the
mainstream news media won't call him
racist they'll say his controversial
comments on immigration and they won't
call them fascist which is exactly what
this is what it looks like right so
they're charismatic they're popular they
demonize the Pima grants and the people
with no money and no power as being the
problem right there over overly nativist
they're naturally they're strong
litter so he's he's got all those 14
hallmark misogyny there's a is big in
fascist regimes right and in their
culture and he's pushing the massagin
ISM right I don't know if that's a word
and that sounded like a word so it's
amazing so what we can southside here
and I say it on my show that that this
is what fact that's people go well how
did Hitler happen well he gave a good
speech he didn't have to appeal to that
many people
and that's exactly what Donald Trump is
doing so that really is so this is just
a show right like to me this is the
ultimate reality show is that at the end
of the day is that really what's
happening here yes I'm sorry the only
thing I want to say about when I watch
Donald Trump is the makeup that he has
on his face and I'm being completely
serious I just had three baby mamas they
all are all gorgeous women that know how
to apply makeup and the fact that he
doesn't turn to his wife or one of the
former baby mamas and go do you think
this is too much orange too much wine
under the eyes says to me this is a
person that doesn't give a [ __ ] about
anyone else's opinion or doesn't care no
I'm sick oh yeah least serious attorney
as a silly woman that I am I'm all like
there's something wrong with that guy
that he can't turn to his woman and say
what do you think well you know what's
rubbing I be able do that with any
subject he can't turn to his woman cuz
she you know he's women are anchor wives
I don't know
last thought out him I mean is there
something really psychologically sort of
void in someone that's answer to
everything is they love me and I'm gonna
show you why they I look forward to
Donald Trump's next speech where he
calls another group of people rapists
and then ends it with but they love me
but they love yeah yeah exactly
all right so let's move on to the other
one which the other big one which is
Hillary and to me it seems like Hillary
is running I think the worst campaign
probably in modern history
forget the email thing and the you know
inaccessibility of the press there seems
to be just no sort of joy or humanity or
sense of who she is or any of that stuff
are you guys with me on that what do you
think about the campaign itself you're
are correct Dave it is horrible she's at
the beginning of the summer she said
that nobody stands up for progressive
values stronger than she does and then
just the other day she say I'm a
centrist
she's bragging that she
that's what's wrong with the country you
knucklehead is that we the center has
moved to the right so now when you say
you're a centrist you're actually a
Republican from the 90s right hey and
that's the problem so and that's why
Bernie Sanders had such traction and
that's why she's doing such a bad job
but I will say the the email thing it
just goes to prove you because they did
they just came out and said that there
was if you don't commit a crime it will
haunt you for the rest of you okay so
they've said so I guess the State
Department has said that she actually
didn't send any classified emails I
don't know what to believe at this point
but to me the whole thing is sort of
nonsensical because yes one day we're
just going to have a point where the
politicians just won't use email or they
won't use any electronic communication
and they're gonna do all their bad [ __ ]
by just talking to people you know you
mean like so to make it about the emails
itself is sort of yeah it's it's the
March the wound not really what's what's
the underlying problem I don't think
necessarily that she's running a
terrible campaign it could be a lot
better yeah I think when we are talking
earlier in the green room and you were
saying what does she stand for you I
thought that was a great point cuz no
one knows what does she specifically
stand for yeah I mean we know yeah but
house is very democratic but how is that
possible is one thing where you were
like what is Hillary like you can't name
one thing that she likes right so so I
think you generally you basically like
her right like like and I was telling
him earlier I have a picture of the gig
15 years ago of Hillary and me in the
backstage and I'm like I just want her
to be President for that picture I mean
that's a funny answer to the seriousness
of the question yeah the thing is she's
had so much bad news over the past two
or three months on headlines about
Benghazi all the time about those emails
and it's just insane how much people in
America don't want establishment
candidates and that's the problem with
her is she's too establishment you know
that's why Donald Trump is doing good
that's why Bernie Sanders is doing good
people want something different yeah so
I want to get to Bernie in a sec but I
think you hit on something with the with
the establishment and the media it seems
to me that the media loves Trump because
they because of what we said earlier
this off the prompter thing Hillary is
completely scripted and I also think the
media is sort of digging the fact
that Hilary's been around for so long
and it's she's always had this back and
forth with the media and I think they
love just attacking her that in no way
is a defense yes of her but how much is
just that the media just loves a
narrative and now it's like we're gonna
take down this woman yes that's that is
exactly what you know and and not that I
want to defend Hillary Clinton but you
know it to be - you have to in this
situation because the New York Times has
had like a freakin vendetta against her
over these and the it'll do was nothing
by the way you talk about email hank
paulson who was the secretary of the
treasury when everything went belly-up
right when the whole thing cratered he
never even used emails right and that
not use email right so that's what your
pointers is like well let's make a
bigger deal out of her emails and no one
will put anything in an email that's
important right and by the way we know
that even when you lie under oath we've
talked about this a thousand times like
James clapper who was the head of the
CIA they asked him are we you know doing
this massed data collection and he said
not reading Lee as he was scratching the
top of his head because that's where you
scratch when you're in your life yeah so
we know that even when you lie right
like they're not gonna really do
anything that makes me laugh because
Pottery Barn does mass data collection I
think everybody does they know what you
what you have in your kitchen they do
know what I have in my kitchen yeah all
right so let's move on to Bernie because
this is the one that I think we should
be talking about more and I've been
trying to talk about him more I think
he's talking about the right things
income inequality which was a huge
problem he's talking about money in
politics which nobody is talking about
as I told you guys earlier I went to the
GOP debate I literally think I might
have been the only person that asked
anyone in that room about money in
politics I asked Scott Walker he went
out of the race two days later I mean
that tells you something so that's what
that goes back to your earlier question
about Donald Trump deserves credit for
bringing up this issue yes he does
expose the Craven as' and the and the
emptiness of the political process right
or the I don't know the complete
corruption of the political process but
then no reporter ever says hey what's
your plan to fix that nobody ever says
hey that was great the way you showed
everybody how you buy all these guys on
stage what's your plan to fix that right
and he does not so he's also at the same
time revealing the corruption in the
political process he's revealing
corruption in the news media right so
the news be Chuck Todd had him on and he
asked him the Muslim question right and
he started out this is just Sunday and
he said you know if you say that you
don't have to respond to everybody who
says something and I agree with you on
that that's how he started his question
so he just entered Chuck Todd just
interviewed Donald Trump after the
biggest you know gaffe that you could
ever imagine
right some guy says let's call let's
round up Muslims and by the way the
presidents of Muslim and Trump says yes
to both of them Chuck Todd the number
one political reporter in America has
amount of show doesn't lay a [ __ ]
glove on him
ya hear you cause it later on the delay
and then he's like well thanks for
having and in Donald Trump says there
was a pleasure and you know what Chuck
Todd says you bet yeah that's what he
said so that's what's wrong with the and
if you see go why why why do we have the
biggest income disparity since the
Gilded Age why do we only have five
major media corporations in America when
there used to be 50 in 1980 why can't we
get this Drake told why does it when we
nationalize the banks nobody calls it
that and that's because they're all
bought and paid for by the same people
Reed manufacturing consent right alright
so I think your answer the original
question was what about Bernie and I
think you got there you know a long way
because he is talking about those things
yeah so basically do you think that the
media just has a vested interest in
really not showing him so for example
the other day Bernie and Trump were both
giving speeches at the same time and
even MSNBC which you'd think would be
you know they're supposed to lean
forward or I guess they did until two
months ago now I don't now that they
lean backwards I'm not sure but even
they were covering Trump instead of
covering Bernie so can a Kenan outsider
like Bernie ever really win if he is a
little bit more fun I'm seriously the
answer why people love Trump because
he's fun yeah you can make fun of him it
doesn't hurt his feelings you know and
he is out of the box but when it comes
to Bernie like they they're gonna have
to start putting him on The Tonight Show
drinking wine with you know yeah yes
well I saw he did he did a promo he did
a promo for the nightly show and he said
on fleek which you've ever heard Bernie
Sanders say on fleek it was actually
pretty funny yeah um but yes so how much
of that is it that he's the outsider
guys so he should be getting the Obama
the first time Obama went around he
should
be getting that excitement but but
Bernie himself he's a 70 something year
old white guy from Vermont mm-hmm he's
not that exciting and sad like home yeah
right right like you should shave the
size but but you know I really like how
much is just that that maybe his person
sadly in in 2015 in America that his
personality doesn't match up in the way
we want to vote for somebody the way his
rhetoric which I think a lot of people
agree with you know it's funny that he
he's the big outsider on the left and
Trump is the big outsider on the right
and one of them spend zero time on their
hair and what about here I would like to
ask Donald Trump does he have a
long-form birth certificate for that
[ __ ] hairpiece yeah anyway so that
thing definitely was not born in America
no what do you think you talk about what
you know so in even MSNBC wasn't
covering Bernie right well that's
because MSNBC is not a liberal
corporation they're a corporation by the
way through the whole Iraq war MSNBC was
owned by General Electric which is a
huge defense contractor so the lefties
were left getting their anti-war message
from a [ __ ] defense contractor which
is why they fired Phil Donahue because
he was against the war and they kept
Chris Matthews and then they also just
fired Edie
Schultz because he's against the TPT and
Comcast is all for the TPT so I said I
always said this but they're not liberal
as soon as Rachel Maddow says something
that caused Comcast's money they will
fire her and it's just an embarrassment
to her that they haven't well for the
record or has told me I can say anything
I want no offense oh that's pretty good
that's pretty good I mean it should be
the embarrassment to them and if you
watch the channel like I do you see that
they're corporatists they're not
especially Chris Hayes he's couldn't be
worse yeah all right so my last thought
on this is does he have any chance does
Bernie have any chance
my feeling is no unfortunately and I
know people are gonna give me [ __ ] for
saying that cuz if they'll they'll say
to me if you say no that causes people
to get ya pressed about it and then
they're not going to vote I just
unfortunately I think that it's very
clear to me that the party is going to
not going to back him they simply will
not back him and that's why people are
talking about Biden because I think
Hillary probably will flame out and
they're gonna go with Biden and it's
like you guys are the big party the only
loss are minorities and women and
everything else and we're gonna pick the
VP who's just another old like
why don't they embrace burn is because
he isn't independent and he railed so
hard against both Democrats and
Republicans I think he they think he
can't that a liberal from someone that
far on the left from the Northeast just
can't win the middle of the country I
think it bring us home no I think the
reason why the Democratic Party hasn't
rallied around Bernie is because the
he's not in bed with the big-money
donors and so the Democratic Party no
longer responds to their voters they
only respond to their donors and so
their donors are telling them get rid of
this guy right we got to get rid of that
guy somehow they don't want the donors
want nothing to do with Bernie because
they can't control them just like the
donors don't want anything to do with
Donald Trump cuz they can't control him
so in that sense they're very much alike
and that's exactly what's happening we
do live in a banana republic like we
don't really have a responsive
government I mean the Sandy Hook taught
us anything 90% of people in America
wanted some kind of gun legislation and
we didn't get it so I'll no longer do
our representatives represent our
interests they only represent the donors
and that's why Bernie's winning and
that's why he gets 30,000 people when he
shows up to speak that's how you end a
segment all right so how do you guys
think we can make the debates better
because I've watched both of them as I
said I went to the last one I tweeted on
the first debate that technically these
things have not even been debates a
debate is where they present an idea and
then two or more people go back and
forth on these same ideas but basically
what we've seen is moderators ask people
questions catered to them so that they
can talk about their things so for
example Jake Tapper
would focus with Lindsey Graham on
foreign policy because he's a foreign
policy guy right that's not a debate
that's just sort of lobbing up softballs
so what do you think we can do to make
these things better I'm back to let's
make it fun and entertaining and do it
like the voice comes on yeah three
minutes to talk everyone Wolf Blitzer
they all have their back tombs yeah and
as soon as he says one thing that they
like they turn around and he's in that's
actually not so you mask the voices
right you know it cuz otherwise they'll
know
well that's true that that's that's not
the worst idea I've ever heard I'm just
saying uh the last debate which was on
CNN was fantastic because they instead
of getting a journalist to moderate it
they hired Eddie Haskell
he just kept trying to get everybody to
pick fights with each other yeah now
Donald Trump said to that you are ugly
what do you want to say to him yeah so
you're not a Jake Tapper guy is that
what you're telling me no that was that
was probably the worst by the way Jake
Tapper he just announced that they're
gonna be start doing fact-checking of
politicians with with factcheck.org
because apparently at CNN they don't
know how to do that so they had to hire
outside organization to teach them how
to fact-check that's CNN nobody I'm Jake
Tapper staff really knows what they're
doing right so what that is and why
there was no real questions why there
was no follow-up
there was no Candy Crowley moment at
this debate where they corrected Carly
Fiorina for being a crazy person and
saying blatant lies about Planned
Parenthood what reason they don't do
that because they don't want to alienate
any of the viewers that like these
people so what they'll do is they say
hey Jeb Bush said this Donald Trump said
that what do you want to say to him
instead of saying hey the facts are this
and you said this how do you they don't
do that so they're not doing journalism
they're doing Eddie Haskell ISM and
they're trying to get people to pick
fights with each other yeah I do agree
with you but on the other hand that
question needed to be asked to Karl if
you're good what's the face thing that
needed to be asked oh okay know about
Trump saying you know calling around on
what her looks or whatever I mean that
is right so arrabal that it needed to be
out right so I agree with you it had to
be addressed because it was just another
absurdly misogynistic thing that that
Trump did but interestingly doesn't that
then get more of the play the next day
than anything that might be more
important such as foreign policy or
immigration I mean really can you think
of any headline the next day that was
related to policy sorry another
important things but it's important how
a person who is running for president is
treating the women of this country yeah
I totally is important I totally and the
GOP did make it clear that they welcome
all women into the GOP even the ones who
make Donald Trump wins all right so we
haven't had a democratic debate yet we
have won in a couple weeks in Vegas
right um as I said about in our Bernie
segment you know the Democrats are
supposed to be the big party that's what
everyone says they're supposed to be the
big party but they've really only got
two people running for all
Tencent purposes right Hillary and
Bernie then there's Jim Webb and an
O'Malley well but but it's really only
two people that anyone's talking about
so should we give the Republicans a
little credit for at least they have
twenty clowns in their clown car while
in the Democratic clown car there's
really only two people well Martin
O'Malley did come out last week with a
bold proposal he said raise the age of
gun ownership to twenty one years old
and everybody responded by saying who
the [ __ ] is malli but that's my point
you know I'm gonna cost call something
crazy here I think that that guy who's
polling at negative sixty that nobody
knows who he is I think he has a little
bit of a chance yeah because I think
they're all gonna get equal footing and
people are so sick and Hillary on the
debates yeah and I think I think it will
bring him a good-looking middle-aged guy
and I think he's a pretty decent guy and
I think people are suddenly gonna go who
the hell is this guy the irony is that
it was Howard Dean who whose idea was to
limit the number of democratic debates
because he saw what happened with all
the Republican debates last time and how
they ate each other and how it was just
a clown show and so he didn't want that
to happen with the Democrats so they
made them limit them but now we realize
hey there's actually gonna be a real
debate now so maybe we should do more of
these because this is just free
advertising for the Republican Party
yeah and we're not getting any for the
Democrats and people still don't know
where Bernie Sanders is right so what
can what can we do we got look the
election is over a year away right what
can we do to make these debates better
like it as the people that do we have to
demand that they have to be done on PBS
I mean they were done I don't know
there's gonna be any of this upcoming
year but four years ago some of them
were done up here I mean something how
do we get it out of the gotcha thing out
of the does Carly have a wrinkle right
in the face know what the answer for
that is I mean it is gonna be
interesting to finally see Bernie and
Hillary go at it you know but how do you
make it more interesting and maybe they
you need to have someone like at the
Oscars who did the little clips always
beforehand you know what I mean - like
Billy Crystal come in and write I don't
know it or I mean what are you well it
would be it used to be that the League
of Women Voters used to organize debates
and other people used to and then they
got smart and they were like hey we
can't let other people choose the people
are going to ask us questions we want to
get control
everything so they created this
Presidential Commission on debates and
now there so now there isn't anymore we
League of Women so it's all them
controlling everything which is why they
suck right so somebody has to stand up
like maybe women or some other big
organization say hey we want to have our
own debate like the n-double-a-cp
members hey we're gonna have our own
debate at our thing and we were inviting
people and then it'll be telling who
doesn't show up right so that's the way
they should do it unfortunately we know
the parties won't the parties won't back
that up they won't because they have
Bernie Sanders will show up Bernie will
show up and he'll do it alone but maybe
that would be good all right so let's
move on to what I think was the big
elephant in the room or unfortunately
not much jimmy dore a giant out of it
the money and politics thing it is seems
pretty obvious to me that we have a
couple like real issues in America right
now the money in politics its ruin our
political system we've got you know
political correctness run amok but
nobody talked about money in politics as
I said before I think I might've been
the only person that asked him a
question on this why do we not talk we
did talk about it wasn't there a
mccain-feingold thing you have teen
years ago we used to sort of talk about
it every now and again nobody talks
about it now right talk about it I don't
understand how we allow people to run
for president as a candidate when they
still owe money from the last they tried
literally I think Hillary might be in
debt still from you previously if you
owe money from the last time you didn't
get elected done you can't run this time
until you've paid everybody off it is
striking and outrageous that people
don't mention it or talk about it I
think it's terrible I mean it's that's
the only answer I mean what how do you
fix that though how do you fix that
well I did notice that when I asked some
of the campaign people this and even
when I asked Scott Walker they just they
just link a couple words together to put
to make a sentence and then you move on
because they know they're not going to
be asked this and they know no one cares
that's what I really realized that when
I asked them that there was a sense of
that that stupid question like nobody
cares about that ask me the ask me the
gotcha question you know so what do we
do about that
you know we wolf dash pack.com Dave
that's how we need there's a bunch of
work that's the organization I'm a part
of that helps get money out of politics
and what you have to do is you have to
pass
a constitutional amendment right to get
money out of politics Hillary Clinton by
the way said she's in favor of it so we
don't well that'll be that's good to
hear also the Senate also if the united
states congress also passed a resolution
to open debate on this well that's a
good thing and three states since we've
been trying to push this i've already
passed a california being one of them
illinois and i think we have new
hampshire of vermont so that's what you
need to do you need to get the states
you have to go to the state level they
have much less control for whatever
reason on the state capitol sure so we
can make and so that's my big solution
we have to get money and you can't fix
anything why are we still debating
climate change because big money right
why are we still debating wish we drill
in the Arctic because of big money i why
are we still bombing non-stop for thirty
years in the middle these big money so
is that that so that's really the crux
of it that the reason we can't get the
public to be ginned up enough to care is
because they're getting their
information from the very people who are
paying the operation to keep them dumb
the criminals bought the watchdog right
the watchdog used to be the Walter
Cronkite in 60 minutes and then they got
smart and said hey let's just buy them
yeah and they bought them and so now the
guys who are working for the people are
supposed to be exposing so that's why
they are literally working so that's how
you go well how do we so how do we get
it a rack war that lasts that's how you
get it because the people are working
for defense contractors they're supposed
to be exposing defense contractors and
they're not that's what's brought you
think there's a reality where it'll ever
turn around uh yes I think if we get
money out of politics and so so Teddy
happen before right so Teddy Roosevelt
came along and he did the antitrust
legislation right they used to call him
trusts back then because they would take
anyway that was the so now that's what
we need we need him and then we need FDR
FDR stood up and said never before in
the history of America has the moneyed
people been more organized in their
hatred for one candidate and I welcome
their hatred could you imagine can you
imagine anyone anyone saying that today
besides Bernie sander right so you I had
a little inspiration from you first
because it sounded like it could happen
but then I just thought well if we get
Hillary as president or let's say we get
Jeb Bush pretty sure they're not making
that speech I think we're gonna have a
revolution if that happens
who we may well never it I'm gonna buy a
gun yeah all right so let's uh let's
talk about religion in politics because
that's the other big one and look a guy
Mike Huckabee's up there this is a guy
that the week before was defending Kim
Davis everyone knows about Kim Davis and
not giving the marriage licenses to gay
people and Mike Huckabee actually
defended her by saying you shouldn't you
shouldn't you know partake in a law that
you don't believe is moral that is the
most ridiculous anti-american thing you
could possibly do it shows a profound
lack of understanding of how government
works at our Constitution and all that
so but there's there's him there's Cruz
there's Santorum and these got an even
now ben Carson what do we do about this
conversation religion should have
nothing we have separation of church and
state I think what do we do about - well
I was googling this topic matter earlier
and I saw that the Boy Scouts don't
allow atheists in the Boy Scouts right
and I was thinking it's people don't
want to trust other people who aren't
religious or can pretend to be religious
you know with decisions that are going
to impact them I kind of get it but on
the other hand have you ever been around
I have ants that are so religious they
are evil you know I've never been around
people like that yeah you know I went to
Catholic school right right that's what
you mean and and when I look at the
Republican spectrum out there the
candidates I'm like oh my god these
people are evil yeah if you have
blinders like this about religious and
how everyone has to follow the same
religion or the same thing that you're
doing I mean that is just as bad as
someone who has a void of it and I know
that's just as bad as those horrible
atheists we don't want to hurt anyone I
want people to live with secular values
I know it's just as equally horrible Wow
but is this is this the irony of is this
the irony of Republicans that they say I
want small government right yes they say
they want small government and then at
the same time they keep
jamming jeering my no everyone i didn't
note because you said your question is
how do we get real engine out of
government and my whole thing is they
should be made to go to an religious
people should have to take an iron class
yeah right right ab kim davis who's
thrice divorced s-- making a religious
stand for the sanctity of marriage yeah
that's you know and now the oath keepers
have promised to defend her in cave they
don't want to lock her up again right
she's so grateful she promised to marry
three or four of them yeah so and then
they played that song right do it with a
tiger and so when she came out and she
and they that she got in trouble for
that because they don't want her
survivor doesn't wanna use that song
yeah she said she liked that song so
much she's gonna play it in her next
three weddings the point is dave i have
a lot of these jokes yes i got there and
she ruined rocky you for me it's like
yes so but what about Huckabee so
someone like Huckabee who's supposed
like to me this is this is proof that
he's not running for president and he's
running to run the Christian Right yes
and I wish people would just say that I
wish almost he could say that and he
could say you know what I'm up on this
stage because I do control or at least
want to control a portion of this
country and I want to keep controlling
it and then we could be honest about it
and then he would disappear when he gets
yeah when the primaries go further but
he's not really running for president
right isn't he running to its own that
degree of power I think you're a very
perceptive day this is I think why you
have your own show once in awhile and
yes that is exactly what he's doing he's
running to get speaking fees he's
running to be the biggest Christian
onstage sanam whoever does become
president he's like the Billy Graham
they have to come through him to get to
the religious right that they're gonna
need so it's all that he's the biggest
charlatan of all of them yeah because at
least that'll trump who's a big [ __ ]
won't take that extra step of putting
the cross on his sleeve like like
Huckabee was and Huckabee his complete
phony right and then Trump not that I
ever wanted offend Trump but you know
they asked Trump about the gay marriage
thing and he said look the Supreme Court
made a decision I I would have to abide
by the supreme words that shows a better
understanding of how government works
then Santorum or Huckabee who want you
to just pick which laws can you imagine
if we could all just pick well I'm not
gonna pay taxes morally I don't think I
should have to yeah separate but equal
so that means we can just ignore it no
that sounds at Haeundae right but I do
like what you're saying about he's
running to get a speaking engagement but
then the reality is how much money is he
spending to try to run for president
versus how much he would actually ever
make as this but he's not spending his
own money right so he's not yeah right
it's not it's not his and ultimately
it's not about the speaking money per se
as much as just the influence that he
will just won the Christian Right like
be the next Billy Graham but I want to
back up to saying that you said earlier
about this this atheist thing because
the first two episodes of the show we
had Sam Harris who's probably the most
outspoken atheist one of my top it what
if Jimmy's favorite is I love and Cara
Santa Maria also an atheist and we
talked a little bit about atheists in
politics and every poll shows that
people would never vote for an atheist
people hate atheists why are we so
afraid of secularism I think this is
sort of what you were saying before but
why are we afraid of people that would
that would base their decisions on the
law of the land and not the imaginary I
think it's cuz everyone has this like
ultimate fantasy of the press you get to
be President something terrible goes
down somewhere he has his finger on the
button right like what what's gonna
happen you want to know that your
president is going to be in that dark
space in his room before he has to make
some terrible decision like dear God you
want the comfort of knowing it's a whole
facade it's a fake but you want that you
know anything you don't want someone
that's just like and this is the line
the column of good things that'll happen
this is the column of bad things I think
because people want to be able to hang
hope on a president and as weird as it
sounds I think what it is you don't hang
up on you know sorry I'm sorry but okay
no that's so I think it's the same thing
with gay people
people were against gay marriage until
they knew a gay person and I think
people are afraid of atheists until they
know an atheist yeah I was against gay
marriage till I got gay married um now
I'm okay with but I'm what do you think
about I that's what I really think it is
yeah people just don't know atheists and
they think well they're thank you Monday
in fact they kind of equated with devil
worshipers right you know it's like you
know there are no worshipping yeah
nothing which is exactly why I've been
saying on the show repeatedly yeah the
atheists have to come out I think the
Atheist movement should do that the most
important thing that gay people ever did
was come
out and I think that that's what's next
for a theater maybe we should start
calling ourselves something else like I
like the term non-theist yeah
I like that it sounds better doesn't
it's like I'm not into the [ __ ] right
but don't you hate that you even have to
associate with the term doesn't that in
itself it's like then you're in the club
and yeah what club would want me a kind
of thing yes and that yes and I don't
agree that there's such a thing as
militant atheism I don't I don't agree
that's like saying you're a militant
logical person yeah yes I will apply
logic lunchbox every situation right you
know all these atheists that are getting
rallies together to hurt people it's
just not happening snot it's alright
well that's a perfect segue to the next
thing I want to talk about which is the
PC culture that we seem to live in so I
have two comedians this is our job more
than anything else is to is to get to
that line and figure out where it is and
push it maybe cross it every now and
again I think we live in a very bizarre
time where we have trigger warnings now
and the social justice warriors and
every time anyone says anything about
you say something about women they don't
like they bet you're now you hate women
you say something about any minority you
don't like are you saying about gay
people you automatically hate all of
them that we automatically jump to the
conclusion that it's based in racism or
xenophobia especially for comedians this
is a seriously dangerous slope right you
know is the worse with that the Puerto
Ricans watch yeah you watch no I honest
yeah yeah I don't think it's so much
about PC culture I just think everyone
has a knee-jerk reaction people are like
this now why are people like this now
everyone is so angry and no one just
wants to enjoy jokes or have fun anymore
every everything has to be a purpose
like now they have the new normal Barbie
it's a Barbie doll that has stretch
marks and pimples a normal Barbie and
that's it right I did you know why can't
people just have toys not reading a
million things why does everything have
to have a hundred percent purpose or you
know you mean be without any humor
anymore don't you think that that
actually takes something very special
away from childhood that you know I
played with GI Joe or he-man or
transformers and the imagination I got
to use my imagination to make up this
world and you know figure out things
that I thought
and whatever where now you're gonna make
everything so realistic for these kids
and aware them of every fear and
everything that might upset them that
you're going to send a bunch of robots
and by the way they're drugged right
they're all on every drug known to man
because of you know whatever that we're
going to send them out into a world
drugged and afraid of everything that's
pretty dangerous combination right you
know getting back to the PC thing you
are correct that some people are to
knee-jerk and cry racism or and whatever
anti-semitism oh sure and there is so
that's the thing that's where it's like
murky right here like well I don't want
to get into a point where we just shout
this or not because the right wing does
a thing where they show every time there
actually is racism they go oh you're
just two PC no that's not being two PC
right so that for example that would be
when the right will say that Christians
are actually the most under attack in
America which is of course when are the
Christians gonna have their day in
America Dave someday they're gonna have
a guy maybe in the White House yeah
to run things so yes you know the thing
that Jerry Seinfeld right so that came
up with he was complaining about PC
culture on campus I haven't in colleges
in a year but I mean in a couple of
years but I noticed when I used to play
colleges that the higher the tuition the
more freedom I got to say whatever I
wanted
and that's interesting yeah the so the
lower the tuition you know I don't know
if the Dumber the kids or whatever I
don't know I want to [ __ ] that's very
politically incorrect I know that's
politically incorrect so I went to
shitty school and I'm a dumb guy so I
can say that and uh to look up where I
went yeah equity Yale the point is it
sucked George Bush went there yeah that
whole thing trigger war yes yeah it's
crap i when i first for of course yes
there's gonna be someone who reads
something and it's gonna [ __ ] them up
well you can't pass a law about it yeah
you know that's their own problem they
have to deal with you know what I hear
when I hear car horns I freak out I
can't pass a law that says nobody can
beat their horn anymore right so is the
bigger fear I used to fear that the
First Amendment would disappear that the
government would take our free speech
but what I'm starting to fear now
although I am no big fan of the
government in any capacity what I'm
starting to fear now is that ultimately
we're just gonna take our freedoms away
we're gonna get so afraid of saying
anything and I see this happen all the
time now
I get emails not that I'm the most
politically incorrect person there is
but I get emails now people saying that
I'm saying things that they wish they
could say and it seems to me that people
are censoring themselves already so I
fear that I fear the self-censorship
because of all the yes more than I fear
that the government's going to come in
and take away our right to free speech
to you where do you where do you fall on
it well all I want to say this I was
just working Vegas last week and I there
was one set where I was having it was a
little the crowd was tight and a guy was
sitting with his arms crossed and I for
15 years ago I said oh you know our
interpose cold you want to let him go or
you know three guys sitting you guys
where's girls and all that we're that
you know that is totally hacky but it
kind of gets a crowd you know going when
you're in the mood but now people don't
buy into those jokes yeah it was a
realization of wow people really are PC
but it's a good thing like so I think
there is a legitimate reason to be PC
we're growing as people and and there
are things we don't accept anymore we
don't accept racism anymore we don't
accept making jokes about gays anymore
and that's a good thing I think the
comedian's that say oh it's too PC to PC
they might be correct but in other words
maybe you need to change too yes it's me
to church there's the idea that's
interesting because Sarah Silverman said
something to that effect this week in an
interview and I think she was directing
it at Seinfeld because Seinfeld
basically was saying you know I used to
make this gay joke about a French King
and his loose you know his hand like
this and now they think it's too
offensive but I would always veer on
this I don't know but you took all
Seinfeld politically incorrect I don't
know what he thinks about anything you
know what Gary's I know things about any
did you hear what he said about that
cotton ball
yes exactly all right so my way my final
one final thought about this because
there's comes a time right like so now
we've come a long way with how gay
people are treated in our society in a
positive way but there's guys who were
born in a certain age like Alec Baldwin
they grew up using gay terms as slurs
and insults right and then when that
lizard brain gets activated when you're
angry at someone those things come up
right and so Alec Baldwin got in trouble
for calling a guy a [ __ ] [ __ ]
right he said he called him a
[ __ ] Fathead
cuz apparently [ __ ]
gender-neutral well no one swears like
that no one nobody says a $4 swear word
and then files it up with a cartoons
record nobody goes oh you mother [ __ ]
fart snorkel right right so that's so do
you get those people a little bit of a
leash then if you grew like animal yeah
yeah
I especially if he apologizes or are
lies or lies about it like I bawled with
Dave right know if he apologizes look my
dad said racist things when I was
growing up my dad would never do it now
but he's your dad Bull Connor no he's
but when I was growing up as a 27 year
old man or a 30 year old man he said
stuff and my brother me would be like
during and now he would never do that
because everyone grows at a different
rate you know people are learning at
different ages and you know yeah alright
so I apologize at least oh yeah so I
thought that the the right way to end
something with comedians would be to
talk about counterculture a little bit
because counterculture is what you know
stand-up grew out of right
it used to be cool to fight the system
yes and I feel like it's not cool to
fight the system anymore your thought of
as crazy or something or something I
think it has a lot to do with that most
comics are liberal most comics really at
least at the beginning really liked
Obama so everybody would say yeah it's
tough to make jokes about this guy
because he's rational and speaks clearly
and he's not making all the grammatical
errors that Bush was making now it's
changed and I think people don't
necessarily like Obama as much or at
least people on the left that feel that
he's you know been more right-wing I
think certainly that's what you think so
but we don't have a real counterculture
anymore how do we need a Republican in
office to have a true counterculture
Wow would that actually help the country
people to have someone that I believe in
nothing that they actually stand for the
argument but that would struggle the
argument has been made that Barack Obama
being the head of the government right
now splits the opposition because
they're the people so we should be
opposing him about the indefinite
detention TPP you know all that stuff
that Syria or with you Walsh yeah maybe
yeah we've known everybody know you and
I on the same page on this a week
so what by Barack Obama being the head
of the government he splits the
opposition because half the people are
loyal to him and then the other half the
people are telling the truth are wanting
to push back and protest against you
know a tyrannical government or [ __ ]
that they see in the government and so
it doesn't happen that's exactly what's
happening and that is what happened and
that's why there is no counterculture
good interview to pick up on it I get a
couple every episode I get one or two
yeah bring us on bring us well I was
watching Bill Maher the other night and
he was of course making fun of
Republicans and George Pataki was on
there and it's gotten to the point where
yeah you want to have one Republican in
the mix when you're talking politics and
doing the counterculture thing all that
but even George Pataki is like well my
party and it's just an indication of
we've just all moved to the right right
so maybe we do need a Republican office
to wake up the people to actually
realize what's important yes and and it
would be at least be good for comedians
all right on that note I want to thank
Felicia Michaels Jimmy Dore you can
follow them on Twitter and YouTube and
websites they got all that stuff and
we're gonna put my move it right beneath
you when Jimmy's got a book it's called
your country's just not that into you
yeah beautiful bill more all books are
sold everywhere there you go alright
thanks for watching guys and we will do
it again next week